hi I'm Ellie Kemper and today I'll be
doing the wired autocomplete interview
from home the first one says can Ellie
Kemper can Ellie Kemper stay I can show
you the world does that answer your
question yeah I can say can Ellie Kemper
improv yes I can I've got my start in I
guess acting by doing improvisation at
The Upright Citizens Brigade theater and
the people's Improv Theater yes and can
Ellie Kemper yoga I am so bad at yoga I
do something called bar method which is
like a strengthening um regimen but I
can't I'm not very flexible the next
question is how ellie kemper how did
Ellie Kemper become famous I like to
think that I gained recognition for my
role as Erin Hannon on the office which
is great NBC show which is a great
comedy that I was lucky enough to get a
part in I started laughing in the middle
of that because it sounded like I was
doing press for the office or something
you can catch it now on NBC which you
can't it's not on NBC anywhere catch it
on Netflix okay how Ellie Kemper teeth I
don't want to brag but I have really
great teeth I had a wonderful
orthodontist dr. Shaheen in Saint Louis
Missouri and he did a great job aligning
my teeth when I was I think in seventh
and eighth grade and now I floss every
night I brush twice a day but I only
floss at night I was wearing a retainer
up until like five years ago and then I
lost it but so far they're hanging in
but my routine isn't even that
extravagant it's just you know what it
is its dedication so I do it every every
night like close people
the next question is was Ellie Kemper
was Ellie Kemper in hairspray no was
Ellie Kemper on the office you know I
was I played Erin Hannon on NBC's the
office I would say Erin is probably in
Scranton and I hope that she found love
but also I hope that she is um you know
happy in her job and maybe has a family
I don't know
but I bet she's in Scranton was Ellie
Kemper pregnant yes Ellie Kemper was
pregnant I was pregnant I have two boys
on eight month old named Matthew and a
three year old named James so young but
all of a sudden me has four teeth on top
it's crazy that's how long we've all
been quarantined my baby now has teeth
the next one is where ellie kemper
where does ellie kemper live that's none
of your business but i live in new york
city and that's all you're getting
where is ellie kemper from Ellie Kemper
is from st. Louis Missouri go blues
where did Ellie Kemper go to high school
Ellie Kemper went to John Burroughs
school in st. Louis Missouri one notable
alumnus school is John Hamm maybe you've
heard of him where is Ellie Kemper new
book my new book is my squirrel days and
it's not so new anymore it's nearly two
years old but you can buy it wherever
books are sold
my squirrel days by Ellie Kemper where
is Ellie Kemper running I don't know
what am i running from I run in Central
Park I run in st. Louis when I'm in st.
Louis and I run when I'm traveling for
work but I don't know what it is I'm
running from the next one is who Ellie
Kemper who are Ellie Kemper is parents
my parents are the best mom and the best
daddy
on the planet daddy Kemper and David
Kemper and in fact during this
quarantine period
I've been staying in st. Louis and so
this is actually my parents home but
they're not anywhere near me otherwise I
would be wearing a mask and staying very
far away from them who is Ellie Kemper
like some people say that my face looks
like Renee Zellweger's face that's just
something that's been thrown out there
but who is Ellie Kemper like as she i'm
unlike anyone I've ever known before the
next question is what Ellie Kemper what
did Ellie Kemper a study at Princeton I
got a Bachelors of a Bachelor of Arts is
it Bachelors of Arts Bachelor a Bachelor
of Arts I didn't study that I got my
undergraduate degree in English
literature at Princeton I wrote a thesis
called isn't it ironic which is the name
of an Alanis Morissette song that was my
thesis what is le Kemper's age guys I
just turned 40 years old I'm 40
what is Ellie Kemper famous for I would
like to think I'm known for parts in
really good shows like The Office and
unbreakable kimmy schmitt and a great
movie bridesmaids and I also um I wrote
a book but I'm trying to sell during
this interview my squirrel days by Ellie
Kemper what is Ellie Kemper voice acting
um I've done some voiceover work
probably my biggest part was Sophia and
the show Sophia the first I voiced
crackle the dragon the next question is
does ellie kemper does ellie kemper have
a sister yes I have a sister named
Carrie Kemper Carrie is a writer she
lives in Los Angeles she has written for
Silicon Valley the office baskets she's
my best friend Carrie and I were on the
office at the same time and it was so
much fun because we would would have
lunch together every day in my trailer
and yeah I miss working with her she's a
good egg does Ellie Kemper sing we've
established that but yes I can to sing
some more if you want um happy birthday
to you sir does Ellie Kemper field
hockey yes I played field hockey I
played field hockey at Burroughs in st.
Louis and then for one year in college
does Ellie Kemper natural hair color now
what a question for florentine my
natural hair color is red I am a born
and bred redhead however I am 40 years
old I have gray hair but my natural hair
color is red however I I think I did a
good job with the roots pray today
bragging Wow Internet thank you for
asking those questions because now I
don't have to worry about the answers
anymore
thank you for having me today wired and
everybody watching stay safe and I hope
that everyone is hanging in there